hi am Maya
Arkin it's not urin it's skin hi I'm
Donald clever I'm Maya urin and we're
going to take a little quiz about little
little little little okay what was it
tell me again oh
coar
co I'm not tired hi I'm Donald Glover
I'm Maya erskin and we're going to test
each other and how well we know our
co-star that guy I think I'm going to
eviscerate
[Music]
oh oh we got phones we get to keep this
this is great the first time you met
each other New York New York Carbone no
it wasn't in New York it was in LA at
Fran's house we all with all the writers
the writers and we all down and we talk
their favorite memory from filming Mr
Smith you know I I know you know I feel
like you know I mean I don't know there
were several but one of them the one
I've talked about a lot I don't listen
to what know you don't you don't retain
anything I say most of the time that one
is that your favorite I mean it's one of
them I love shooting that one there's a
fart scene that you really really
enjoyed I did yours ah oh I I do know
but I don't think I said this out no
give a hint cuz I give you one my yeah
my favorite restaurant in New York
bouvette right the Smith's house was
there yeah I loved shooting in the west
that was really nice really nice
favorite project of yours Atlanta name p
yeah I'm like not sure if we're doing
this correctly we're not doing it right
like she's over there she's like yeah
I'll have to edit this my
goder hate these guys okay a
former co-star of theirs that they'd
love to work with again ASAP I know
Michaela Cole yeah her
husband oh mine yeah for you yeah yeah
you're like what the hell I know I'm
like
you don't ever say anything about his
name in your mouth oh you know this
about me their Roman Empire I.E the
random things they're always thinking
about um lunch yes like L first of all
my always knows what's next she always
just just like we're going to get out
here at 600 because we got four more of
the I'd be like damn I hav even notice
but we always I'll just put it in my
butt it's up my ass oh my God was it up
there before it was up there and I was
holding it just released you the random
thing you're always thinking about
you're always sing in your head and you
don't even realize it so I feel like
lyrics music notes I'm always making up
little songs the genre they'd like to
star in next you've been talking about a
movie that you want to make it's epic
it's like a big action mhm epic it's
like action sci-fi again and sci-fi
right you've done romcom I don't think
like you're like itching to do it
necessarily again although you like it
and you've done Star Wars you you like
you like big active moments you like you
like like sinking my teeth yeah you like
sinking your your teeth and you hate it
when I'm like you're really funny cuz
you're like I'm a
serious actor so I feel like you
probably want like a drama like a deep
drama I did but now actually I'm like
dying to do a comedy again oh really
weirdly yeah like a like a physical like
Jim Cary like go crazy okay so I got
that wrong no but I would do I want
drama to you got the point I'm serious
actor the TV show current or past that
they'd love to guest are on Sopranos the
most famous person in their contacts
well that's tough on a metric level
probably Usher but you just answered
yours sorry Usher I don't know why I was
going to say Steven Soderberg I don't
think I have him in my phone though okay
I don't get in touch with him that way
there's a special way that famous people
get in touch with no oh I'm just like
exposing I know everybody hackers are
like oh that'd be nice oh yeah oh sure
yeah that makes sense for you your dad
it's not the most famous I guess it'd be
Donald one of embarrassing that is so
embarrassing embarrassing the last text
they sent you you sent me a a bar that
was in New York and you're like this
place looks amazing I did what did I say
I remember what you
said I'm telling the last time you sent
me something Boba I sent you like an
article was like I took a screenshot and
you didn't
respond their favorite way to unwind
after a long day on set watch something
and eat something and bath yeah bath
yeah like just be warm I just remember
you talking about like you just want to
be warm something like Ramen m or
something very cozy and watch something
yes yours is watch Jo and like run I
think you did a I feel like an ice an
ice bath no I don't not to unwind but
you did
morning good night no you you would just
take it anable and relax yeah I watch
something family yeah play with the kids
the rule they're most proud of feel like
it's Lando or ER it's interesting I
guess I would say pin 15 yeah that's
like a very personal and big undertaking
in general would it be Atlanta for you
because you created it or would it be a
movie that you were in I think it's the
same thing where I was feel like it l
yeah can't beat that there go to s s is
it a Michael Jackson song no no it's an
older song think Batman Forever
soundtrack you too no no but it's
interesting but they are on there I
would kissed by a r there we go do you
have a good I don't know what you I've
been doing Disney songs lately just
because I sound really good on them for
some reason that's like a good I can
show
you and then weirdly Creep by radio head
is like a really good ballad for me has
someone else done that that is like the
go-to white man song well I'm not a
white man I know you're not but I don't
know why you CH you chose it I didn't
mean to it just came up and I was like
wow I can belt on this song I think
that's why it is it's like no one sound
sounds bad it actually helps if you
sound bad like but you can't really do
yeah but I don't think you can sound cuz
it's like I'm a creep it's like the
feeling of it my mom's friend cried
while I was singing it she was like I
was like it's not that good it's just
she just never heard that song Woody
Haralson that's his goto oh really yeah
I'm a Los
loser is it what the hell about my my
22-year-old assistant is like I don't
know what the you guys are doing um
oh you know what's also good is
Cranberries
Zombie that was like one of the first
singles I ever bought but zombie is like
the in
your zomie
zomie
zombie when we were doing karaoke that
when anyone was doing songs from the
'90s it was actually like very
satisfying like that that time per I was
like so nostalgic for that time so
innocent in those songs there was an
autotune so a lot of it had to do with
the character it was an identity you can
latch on to if it's like Alanis Mor said
or if it's back stre whatever it was
just such a a strong a strong like point
of view yeah their first job 30 Rock
because you were like job being like I
got paid for it yeah like an acting
because you were writing it and then
weren't you in it or no that's no it's
true I was on a 30 rck episode I guess
it was in plays and stuff but I guess on
TV yeah it might be the first first one
well you're in Cali I was about to say
if you were in New York I'd be like I
was in New York
but no but no TV in New York I was doing
theater and then in La my first one was
CW CW Heart of Dixie I played a southern
Asian I like that like what's my
character truly I had one Southern Asian
I had one line and I wish I still had it
but it's like The Comeback where all
night she's like practicing her one line
like and she's eating chocolate cake
what was that app called on oh photo
booth I have photo booth videos of me
saying my one line like you going to
take that seat
over all night like in my mouth guard in
the morning and they cut me from it they
cut Welcome to Hollywood it was blown
away you got paid didn't you their go-to
drink order cappuccino okay sure I'll
give it to you ears is green tea right
now or no no no the golden latte there
you go do you guys have to go to like
Bobo orders I mean like if I'm just like
having a good day and I want to I just
basically get the brown sugar milk like
with all the fixings I'll get it with
like the Boba and the jelly the custard
and like you know the karma like but
there's one called hangover cure it's uh
good for like after hang cuz it's a
little salty but it's got like the plum
the like dried plum at the bottom Umi
yeah and it's so good it's it's it's my
favorite I like like black tea the milk
tea milk tea one classic and then also
on sautel there used to be a place and I
would get the passion fruit slushy one
passion fruit slushie with Boba and the
Taiwanese popcorn chicken those two has
a combination you the one like did you
put that in there we're working on it do
it I'm going to the popcorn though okay
13 out of 14 you they're basically
Family Y very
sweet that really
hurt all right thank you BuzzFeed watch
Jack Reacher every Thursday at 8
uh and Mr and Mrs Smith is that what
we're promoting I don't know anymore
watch uh Mr and Mrs Smith
uh February 2nd on Amazon Prime we're
just as goofy there as we are here
[Music]
mhm